so we broke down a bunch of [ __ ]
great comments on the internet on
Instagram on our Twitter and the YouTube
channel we got people to ask real estate
questions just any or just any questions
we happen to ask questions for you Matt
Cox and the fans have spoken and the
people have spoken
these are genuine now they're gonna know
they're gonna get the straight from the
horse's mouth what they need to do with
their lives and Shane is gonna read the
questions general comments armies kick
in more and more Thank You Stu ball
appreciate you read his name first read
the guys uh his name on whatever social
media platinum writing all these we'll
start with one then we'll expand on it
and move on to the next one all right
this is Scott's thoughts th five months
ago
yes thoughts th OTS this man literally
mastered the same system put in place to
financially trap us he's the Robin Hood
of Fine Arts Danny printed half of them
are questions half of them are just
comments all right here's here's a
question next question when did he start
grifting again was it ten fifteen years
he was doing it if he was 37 when he got
caught 15 years living like a king for
26 years in prison and now he's an
author with movie royalties coming in
morality notwithstanding sounds okay to
me freedom is whatever you have the
privilege to do with the poverty is a
prison without bars
edek I'm everything he said was wrong
but how so can you expand on that yeah
it's out I don't even know what the
questions were the first one is when did
he start grifting again yeah
what again first he says again so again
let's go let's just go grey list did you
see the movie grifters great movie never
seen Oh with John Cusack no wow it
sounds you guys are probably better if
Nic Cage was in it yeah I answer okay
look so what I'm saying is bit the first
time I ever committed a crime mm-hmm was
was the one of the first mortgage I ever
did Debbie Boyd first mortgage I ever
did I could that's why whited out a
30-day late so I wasn't there was no
grifting or any there was no short cons
there was no build up to it was a I was
in desperate straits and I committed
fraud and then I continue to commit
mortgage fraud now those types of that
type of fraud ends up lending itself to
credit card fraud identity theft there's
all these other frauds that start to
take place right bank fraud that sort of
thing because you start to really figure
out what under how underwriting works
and what they're looking for and what
debt-to-income is and how they verify
things so suddenly other frauds develop
as a result of that so there's lots of
other fraud that isn't directly related
to mortgage fraud yeah but so I mean I
did that and then I eventually got
caught and I went to prison I got 26
years I did 13 years and it wasn't 15
years it was 10 years and it was not
worth it
it sucked and now I'm writing stories
are you an author with royalties coming
in like they say I am but not big-time
royalties I didn't I might make fifteen
sixteen hundred bucks one month I just
got out of prison I just started
releasing books Spreaker you would won
that lawsuit over war dogs you've been
getting a little bit more right right
well we settled our you settled okay we
settled and I get royalties from some of
the other books that I've had that I
printed what are published while I was
in prison and I get royalties well I get
options from when they reaction some of
the film rights which was the one that
was in Rolling Stone magazine Jett Dukes
of oxy I get a
I'm the option and I get a check for
that but you know it's not like it's
Matt's massive money I'm working on it
man I just got out of prison oh yeah I
have a bit out of custody a year no I'm
not rolling in dough did you see my car
yeah at least you got one don't you know
I crashed my a couple months ago don't
sleep on the highway anyway when you're
behind the wheel
next question Matt can you give us all
an update on how things are standing
with some of your stories being
contracted for movies or series if you
can say anything about it yeah who asked
that question Yves
min Qiang Wow thinking he's Asian
you can't tell yeah it's definitely
possible he's got sunglasses on in the
picture just a name it could be anything
you know it's funny I'm actually trying
to put together a story right now about
these an Asian gang in the late 90s that
were robbing computer chip manufacturing
plants where all over the United States
really I mean they're going in there
getting orders from supposedly from from
China mm-hmm so Chinese manufacturers
are coming in and saying look we need
these chips and they're giving them like
this this manufacturer has you know
whatever a hundred thousand of these
chips
we need them there's no security so they
this Chinese gang would go in there
eight guys would go in they zip tie
everybody all the guards and everything
load up all the chips in a van and then
take off and go sell them for two
million dollars I mean literally it's
like pulling up into a vacant parking
lot and some Chinese official comes and
gives them a thing gives them two
million dollars in a briefcase and they
hand them over the chips and they leave
I mean it's that kind of it's amazing
how did you find out about these guys um
a buddy that I was in prison with did
some of the legal work for some of the
guys and there was like like there's
like 40 of them all over the country
they got arrested they they they robbed
like 10 or 15 different manufacturers
there ends up being a murderer
of course yeah listen it was so bad I
want to say that it was Clinton or once
it was Clinton that basically gave like
a presidential order that said all all
manufacturing plants have to have armed
security because it was so bad there
were so many chips players getting
robbed tell you I've been working on
that story right now I'd love to put
that together I'd be super cool but back
to what's-his-name's store question oh I
forgot the question
oh I don't use min Qiang the question
was about you progressing okay so I have
like 15 to 6 I think I'm like 17 of them
on my website I think but a couple of
them have already been like one of
them's the war dogs one one of them's
oxy Rush which was the which wasn't that
connected to that option so those are
already kind of done I've got two right
now I have two of the stories are
getting I'm being represented by gosh
who's it supposed to be signing a
contract with zero gravity productions
and they're gonna represent me and is it
50 cent is interested in the story of
Jamar towns which is the guy it's called
cash logistics it's on the website
actually I just it's one of the it's on
the on the YouTube channel it's called
cash logistics and it's about a guy that
gets a job at a at a cash moving company
you know like like Brinks yeah he gets a
job there he sets up an inside job they
robbed it for like three or four million
dollars he hasn't he gets himself robbed
you know you know you read in I remember
you telling me this story oh it's a
great story so anyway anyway so and I
know how to read it can't even read so
that's the I there was a woman a
producer named Ann and I talked to her
and she went they looked over the
website and she pitched it to 50 Cent's
manager and he's gonna pitch it to 50
cent and they're talking about option
possibly optioning it so zero gravity is
gonna represent me on that and the other
one is Amedeo story they're interested
in and representing me on optioning
Amedeo story that was a great story
[ __ ]
[ __ ] amazing sorry that one's good so
I mean I'm Tom a moment turning into I'm
doing stuff with apparently we got to
move faster than I thought my fault the
fact is some of the stories are being
nice I mean there's seventeen of them
they're all and they're all no we don't
have to depth about them okay this is a
wrap I wanted it so now we want to make
it last a little bit longer just drop
ten bucks you said they're in it who did
is this money going to be paying for him
to take us out no he said he was
ordering crab legs what are you serious
I was an idea of you are gonna do that
for God I didn't eat because of that I
haven't eaten something somebody send
this man some crab legs keep going I'm
gonna order [ __ ] rice bands thanks
for the the ten bucks appreciate you
this crabby bills Oh since you I'll send
you the equipment to do your own podcast
no you should do your own podcast I
wanna encourage you to do your own
[ __ ] podcast you don't need me okay
you don't need me to hold your hand Matt
he's gonna want to take some of the
money no problem with that all you need
get to that you need is a microphone
microphone eat that yourself your iPhone
here
do your half-ass [ __ ] podcast starts
to come out professional listen here's
the difference the difference is some
people go in the bank and they slip on
the note they walk out with thirty five
hundred dollars if I'm going in the bank
he's getting you everybody we're going
in the [ __ ] vault we're going in and
if when we walk out if [ __ ] goes wrong
we'll deal with it that's not gonna take
your credit card and run it up for $1000
I'm taking the whole [ __ ] house and
I'm walking away with half a million
well good luck the way it is
[Laughter]